regarder
[Musique]
combat images après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'état ne dispose pas de cabines individuelles
dans lequel seule la personne qui est
entrant de celui qui joue
équipement personne d'autre ne touche à tout l'équipement
désinfecter entre les cours pour les plus âgés
sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un jour
Weisz Jon Weber L'équipe de Marc Sallés
pour changer que je signe le champ
photo de l'opération et nous savons que
Images : projets d'expression
[Musique]
et nous essayons de faire beaucoup de ça
classes en ligne
mais ce n'est pas pareil en fin de compte
C'est ce que tu veux réveiller
je veux un endroit
reconnaissance accordée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la maison
toute la journée passe sans pouvoir réaliser
saisir l'opportunité
cette moralité ici dans ce gymnase